opinions hearsay Israeli forces treat
them as collateral damage
dozens of soldiers raided Ramallah in
the occupied West Bank on Thursday to
demolish a house
several families living nearby were
ordered to leave their homes before loud
explosions were hurt
assessing the damage neighbors say some
of the losses are immeasurable
parents tell us that their children are
shaken and have lost any sense of
security
they told us our home wouldn't be
affected so we left but when we came
back to the house it was badly damaged
we weren't allowed to take our
belongings all of our furniture was here
the soldiers destroyed the home of
Palestinian prisoner slam through
and Israeli Court charged him with
killing two Israelis and twin bombings
in Jerusalem in November
two Palestinian journalists who were
reporting on the demolition were hit by
Rubber coated bullets
cameraman rabiel munir says his team was
more than 100 meters away from the site
when he was hit in the abdomen by a
rubber bullet they were evicting
families to demolish the house they
didn't want us the media to show that to
the world after Israeli forces killed
journalist Shireen abuakle they have
been deliberately targeting journalists
they know they're not being held
accountable
the old Knight rate took place just a
few kilometers away from his offices
it's really great and demolitions mostly
take place in the cities of Janine and
nablas in the north of the West Bank as
many fighters are from there is it a
message to the Palestinian Authority
of course it is
that the Israel is occupying all the
Palestinian territories but this is
something that we will not surrender for
whatsoever this Palestinians
Authority Palestinian state is a product
of our sacrifices the fruit the fruit
family is now homeless
in addition to the damaged buildings
Israel does not allow families to
rebuild their homes for several years
unfortunately no one can do anything to
help us against the occupation I just
pray my son is returned to me
the Palestinian Health Ministry says
dozens of people were injured in
confrontations with the soldiers most by
live fire
long implemented the policy of
demolishing the houses of Palestinians
it holds responsible for killing
Israelis this is the seventh home to be
destroyed this year as part of what
Palestinians call Collective punishment
many here say it's yet another reminder
of the violence inflicted by the Israeli
occupation
Ibrahim al-jazeera the occupied West
Bank